en el vídeo anterior les mostré el
cuadrante superior derecho del círculo
unitario y en este vídeo me gustaría
mostrarles todo existen un par de trucos
que les pueden ayudar a recordar el
círculo unitario miren el círculo
unitario es una circunferencia de radio
1 así que este es el punto 10 después
0,1 aquí simplemente estoy identificando
los puntos este es el punto menos 10 y
este es el punto cero menos 1
ahora recuerden que la circunferencia de
un círculo es 2 pi por el radio entonces
como el círculo unitario tiene un radio
de 1 bueno entonces tenemos 2 x 1 o
simplemente 2 pi y ahora lo que hacemos
es sacar los ángulos fíjense a partir
del eje x positivo medimos ángulos
positivos y nos moveremos en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del
eso significa que la distancia que hay
alrededor del círculo es decir el
perímetro es 2 p y por ejemplo si dieran
una vuelta completa en una patineta no
dirían que dieron 2 pirra dianes sino
más bien 360 grados
así que 360 grados es igual a 2 pi ok
así que al inicio de la circunferencia
nos encontramos en cero grados que
también son dos birra dian es entonces
la mitad de dos pisos irradian is y eso
corresponde al punto menos 10 entonces
cuando nos encontramos en pi o también
180 grados estamos en el punto menos 10
ok y por acá tenemos pie entre 2 y abajo
3 pi entre dos entonces tenemos 0 y
entre 22 y entre 2 que es pi 3 y entre 2
y 4 pie entre 2 que es
2 p ahora si partimos el primer
cuadrante a la mitad es decir el
cuadrante que va de 0 grados api entre
dos radiales bueno entonces aquí tenemos
y entre 4 así que si vemos los ángulos
en cuartos tenemos entre 42 y entre 4
que espíe entre 2 y después tenemos 3 y
entre 4 ok
luego tenemos 4 pi entre 4 y después
tenemos 5 pi entre 4
este es el ángulo 5 pi entre 4 después
tenemos 6 y entre 4 que es igual a 3 y
entre 2 y después tenemos 7 pi entre 4 y
después de eso llegamos a 8 y entre 4
que es igual a 2 pi ok y podemos hacer
lo mismo con un ángulo más pequeño si
este es bien 36 que equivale a 30 grados
porque dividimos 180 entre 6 así es cómo
obtenemos 30 grados por
aquí tenemos 60 grados y 60 grados
corresponden a dos y entre seis ok y el
ángulo que sigue sería bueno si éste
speed entre seis del otro lado tenemos
seis pi entre seis pero como buscamos
algo menor a eso entonces este es el
ángulo cinco pie entre seis y si
avanzamos un poco más encontramos siete
pi entre seis y al dar toda la vuelta
nos encontramos en 12 pie entre 6 ó 2
pib pero uno antes de eso nos lleva al
ángulo 11 pi entre 6 o que ahora aquí
tenemos pi entre 3 así que dos y entre 3
se encuentra aquí
este es el ángulo 2 y entre 3 por lo
tanto este sería 3 pi entre 3 cuando
estamos en el eje x negativo y si
continuamos aquí tenemos 4 pi entre 3
por lo tanto 5 pi entre 3 se encuentra
por acá
este es el ángulo 5 pie entre 3 ok ahora
vamos a llenar los valores que
corresponden a cada punto bueno por los
ejercicios del vídeo anterior tal vez
recuerden los puntos entre 3 y entre 4 y
pie entre 6 pero miren primero vamos a
escribir todas las fracciones entre 2 y
después escribimos 1 2 3 y de regreso 1
2 3 y después vamos a poner la raíz
cuadrada en todos los numeradores es
decir la raíz cuadrada de uno es 1 pero
después tenemos raíz de 3 raíz de 2 raíz
de 2 raíz de 3 y 1 esos son los puntos
del círculo unitario que corresponden al
pie entre 3 y entre 4 y pi entre 6
entonces este es el punto que
corresponde a la raíz cuadrada de 3
entre 2,1 medio ok y para obtener los
demás si por ejemplo ya conocemos bien 3
y entonces podemos conocer 5 entre 6
porque los valores son iguales y lo
único que cambia es que ahora nos
encontramos en las coordenadas de x
negativa así que este punto corresponde
a menos la raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2
como un medio am y 7 pi entre 6 también
tiene los mismos valores pero ahora los
dos son negativos entonces tenemos menos
la raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2,2 un medio
y en el caso de 11 pie en 36 ahora la
coordenada x es positiva así que tenemos
raíz de 3 entre 2,2 un medio entonces ya
conocemos todos los valores que
corresponden a los denominadores que
contienen 6 y podemos hacer lo mismo
para conocer el resto por ejemplo el
valor que va en simetría con pie entre 4
estrés pie entre 4 así que aquí
simplemente script
la coordenada x como menos raíz de 2
entre 2,6 de 2 entre 2 y luego aquí
abajo las dos coordenadas son negativas
así que tenemos menos raíz cuadrada de 2
entre 2,2 raíz de 2 entre 2 y finalmente
de este lado la coordenada x es positiva
así que tenemos raíz de 2 entre 2 pero
la coordenada y es negativa así que la
escribimos como menos raíz de 2 entre 2
ok y si hacemos lo mismo con pi entre 3
si aquí tenemos un medio coma raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2 entonces aquí es
menos un medio coma raíz cuadrada de 3
entre 2 abajo del lado izquierdo los dos
son negativos así que tenemos menos un
medio coma menos raíz de 3 entre 2 y
abajo del lado derecho la coordenada x
es positiva así que tenemos un medio
coma menos raíz de tres entre dos listas
este es el círculo unitario espero que
les sirva